[Music]
all right good afternoon and thank you
for joining our session my name is
Martin Gann home and during the six
years that I've been at Google I've
worked on and led the teams that have
delivered a number of the cloud products
you might be using like a compute engine
container engine and kubernetes hi I'm
Lauren
I've been at Google about nine years now
I've worked on Google's API platform so
when you make API calls to Google all of
those go through stuff from my team work
on and also more recently I've been
doing a lot of work on your PC I'm going
to hand you back to Martin who's going
to show you so much things now all right
so what we're going to talk to you about
is based on a lot of our experiences
building and running as large-scale
cloud services at Google and and how we
can bring this kind of learning to
kubernetes and and and we and do folks
so there's a lot been a lot of talk over
the last few years about zero ops and
service computing and how these concepts
allow you to spend less of your time
managing and and dealing with the
infrastructure in effect they can
lengthen that they can let you run
ambitious apps at scale without having
to know all the details so if you use
Google App Engine or bigquery you're
familiar with how they allow you to
focus on your expertise and writing your
business logic or your data processing
and not managing all these machines
underneath the covers so that's kind of
the context so we're going to talk to
you about some technologies that are
currently under development in open
source and that will get you on the way
to being the operate systems at scale
cheaply efficiently and securely so we
consider these building blocks the
beginning of a journey to deliver the
promise of zero ops and service
computing in the integrated hybrid cloud
so all the all the different parts of
your solution stacks whether they're
running in-house on pram or if they're
in a public or private cloud whether you
wrote the components whether you
acquired them from
some third-party will cover all of those
pieces so there are three intertwine
principles that we believe are the
foundation that will get up there
the first is service is not
infrastructure and what we mean by that
is we need to look at a service
abstraction layer and if we do that we
can get away from from dealing with the
infrastructure it's very common for
companies to have in recent years to
have a service catalog that make it
easier for their application developers
to sort of get bootstrap with different
pieces but oftentimes those are just a
piece of infrastructure like a virtual
machine that gets provisioned some
deployment system or scripts run and
install things on them and at that point
it's yours and it's very much like
getting a free puppy and you quickly
learn that getting the puppy was the
easy part you're not going to take care
of it in
in contrast offering manage capabilities
behind an API is the kind of thing that
is allowed to the explosive adoption of
cloud services and and and we'd like to
bring that same kind of thinking to all
the different components that you build
or that you acquire from some other
people so choosing an abstraction layer
and getting it right means a few things
you'll be able to separate the
construction the operation and the usage
of components from each other which
gives you more flexibility in how you
source the components in Heights and how
you manage them you'll be able to inject
key behaviors at or in different control
points in this in this higher level
system along so many of the intent-based
functions that will let you operate at
scale with little or no effort you'll
also be able to compose your solutions
across a wide range of infrastructures
of environments and technologies and
this really brings us to the next
principle interoperability this is
fundamentally about choice and
flexibility about giving you a path from
today to tomorrow and to whatever the
future may bring this includes legacy
components that you already have running
that you use
in-house developed services that might
be more modern third-party software the
service pieces and all these will span
multiple different environments and it's
all about allowing you to choose the
best option for each individual piece
without giving up on the promise of
their ops and server lists and this is a
vision that is only realizable if we
succeed in the third pillar we like
automation at Google we think that you
know teaching computers to execute
repetitive error-prone and large-scale
tasks so if humans focus on value-added
pursuits is a good thing so for example
if you want to apply an enterprise-wide
policy to all of your services that
should be trivial during a community
test and update and then roll that out
to all of your zones or or whatever
geographical spread that you have if no
anomalies are detected and do that
automatically yep that's one of the
things you want to do what if something
wasn't right
automatic rollback so the answer for us
is automate everything so let's touch on
two of the hard problems to solve for
let's just say that networking is hard
being networking right is harder and now
you want to you want to be secure you
gotta be kidding nobody wants to do that
please I don't but so no we talked about
this as a space between the micro
services so the red lines here
represents that space and so the
questions are how do you securely
connect services together to do
encrypted and authenticated access can
you protect against detox or even just
unintentional packet storms credentials
you know that'd be great if you can flow
credentials through the system but not
just one you want key rotation right you
want these things to update and manage
that so those are the kinds of things
that would be better if you didn't have
to deal with the second part is hybrid
cloud or multi cloud that can be hard
you know if you you
use a homogeneous system like kubernetes
for example which is multi-platform you
can run it in many different places and
if you all in on that everything's fine
but most people don't have that luxury
so you have legacy you have virtual
machines now those are the kinds of
things that that you you have to sort
include as you evolve so some of the
questions you might have is well if I'm
using a service on Prem is that
different we have to operate differently
you have to deal with it differently
than a third party acquired service if
it's a you know how do I tell which
services I'm actually dependent on
across my entire solution how do I
enforce company policies across those
what can I only do it on a subset that I
have under my immediate control and how
do I get a handle on the security aspect
of this layout so let's get more
concrete and talk about the service
abstraction so we have partnered with
several other companies around the open
service brocro api which is a relatively
new standard in the making which
originally came from cloud foundry so
those of you familiar with cloud foundry
will will recognize these concepts and
so we're working with with these
companies on adopting and then extending
this this great abstraction and and so
the importance of the standard is that
services that are written for
consumption in the Cloud Foundry
application will be able to be used
unmodified from kubernetes with what
we're going to show you today and vice
versa and so as as people adapt their
services to this model the amount of
places you'll be able to use them is
going to be a great all right so let's
pretend that I am a service provides a
producer and I want to package up
Google's cloud services behind the
broker or inside the broker so that
people can easily consume them
so we're going to expose our child a
smoky eyes like you see them down there
cloud-storage pub/sub big query and so a
broker can have multiple services that
it's able to be a factory for
essentially so this was one of these
cloud sequel so class declares two types
of instances if you look on the cloud
console it has a first gen and a second
generation the broker API has a notion
of a plan the source class can have one
or more plans and so as a producer I
might choose to use Gen 1 versus gen 2
as my as the two plans that I can offer
you so when you when you want to get one
of these if you choose which plan you
want and that can sort of make that
bifurcation there alternately I could
choose a different way to to to factor
it I could say well what if there are
different fundamental sizes small medium
large I could do that you know that's
another thing you can do the plan or a
different type of a way to look at it is
what about standard versus high
availability deployment of kelp sequel
so those are different choices that is a
service producer I have a lot of
flexibility with this API to specify so
when you go and create a service
instance the other service class you
want an instance all you want to use it
so you create a service instance you
also specify which plan you want and so
here are some screenshots from cloud
sequel you see on the left are the
options for Gen 1 and on the right
there's a long scroll the list of
options on Gen 2 and so the circle cur
API allows for the difference between
these two things and in the future the
parameters that are valid for one plan
versus another will be schematized and
so that we can then automate we can
actually have using the user interface
parse through that and present you the
options really nicely and be able to
show you what options are valid for
which plan
so once you've created a logical
instance you want to use that service
from an application and rather than
copying API keys IP addresses
configuring SSL and all those kinds of
things that you today do in the cloud
sequel in the cloud console and then
take whatever information they give you
and apply those somehow to your code to
your config of your applications the
broker API in conjunction with another
piece the service controller which I'll
get to in a second has a way of
configuring and passing this information
directly into your application saving
use of that that's step so to illustrate
this further the service controller is a
logical construct and it's tied to your
runtime environment so here you can see
the dotted box is meant to be a
kubernetes cluster and so inside of that
there is a service controller that
understands what it's like what it means
to be a cougar native application so it
sort of does some of the work in this in
this area so the Service Catalog has a
few purposes one you can register
brokers over there as many as you want
what it does is it asks the brokers what
are the available service classes and
then it sort of creates an aggregated
catalog of those things
additionally the service controller can
can let you send this functionality
doesn't exist today that this is you
know one of the things that we're
looking at is that this is now a control
point where you can apply an policies so
that you can say well useless certain
people can't access the user service I
can sort of lock that down so they can't
bind to instances of it or they might
not be able to create the instances of
it so once the user decides which
seriously want to use for example let's
pick cloud pub/sub they ask the
controller to create an instance of the
class and the controller delegates to
the broker and says hey once you create
this class create an instance from it
and then that in turn goes and does
whatever it does completely opaque you
have no idea what it does it could
provision a large amount of virtual
infrastructure you know many virtual
machines or whatever or it could simply
just in sort of
a row in a database noting that you now
have a virtual instance this is a nice
abstraction because it allows the
service provider to do what we whatever
implementation they want and it's
transparent so see okay so now we have
the service and now we want to bind an
application to it we want to use it from
an application
so here's application is a nodejs
application now kubernetes cluster and
we want to tell the system that we want
to bind these together so we talk to the
service controller create a binding
service controller once again delegates
the broker the broker figures out what
what are the coordinates you know where
is the actual instance what IP address
which port those kinds of things and
again service dependent but that's a
very common type of thing that it
returns and it also returns Prudential
credentials that could be unique for
each binding or could be shared for all
the bindings to a particular instance
again this is a service it is part of
the service definition so as a sorts
producer you can choose what makes sense
in your scenario and the last step to
the service controller does is that it
sort of creates the virtual binding and
inject those credentials and those
coordinates into the application so they
can very easily consume it and I'll show
this in the demo in a few minutes so
yeah in kubernetes this is done through
secret and config maps and the
application just accesses them through
environment variables okay so here the
pieces are going to talk to talk to you
today so these are three different
open-source things I talked about the
service broker I hinted at the Service
Catalog that's what I call the source
controller so Service Catalog is a
special interest group that's part of
kubernetes and so we're doing work there
in the communities community to add that
capability to kubernetes and service
mesh is something that Louis will get
into depth on and it's another open
source project that the method that
we're engaged in and it's actually
called SPO and
we'll get to the URL so that later
alright so the so what these do we talk
about what the broker does the core
service abstraction and the catalog
basically provides environment specific
health to sort of get consumption of
services to be something that is very
natural in an environment in this case
kubernetes and the Met and the mesh is
for traffic management and Inter service
policy controls ok so this is the
application we'll show you in the demo
what we have here the grey boxes are
existing microservices in my deployment
and so well what we're going to do the
application is the purpose is to have a
bookstore to sell some books so we want
to have a front-end that shows you the
books and allows you to buy them very
very very simple app and I suppose we're
already selling other items sneakers or
something else and that's why we already
have these inventory and payments
connections so we will add the the books
front-end application you'll bind us to
the existing micro services and then
we'll get to pub/sub in a second all
right all right so can we keep switching
the demo machine and went to sleep so
I'm going to okay so here's the
kubernetes dashboard and we have a few
new things on the left irritable Service
Catalog and here we can see the service
classes that were that are available for
for creation if we look here there's one
is there's a couple of catalogs is a k8s
one which is really our department
catalog these are the microscopes that
we built in-house then we should put
them in a broker in a catalog there but
we don't need to create any of these
because we already have some pre created
instances for the purposes of this demo
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
switch over to going to run a scrip
to install the application so this is
really just creating a deployment in
kubernetes using llamo file but I've
just wrapped it up enough in shell
script and so that will do some work
there we go we have created something
and so I say shoot control get pods we
will be able to see oh there we go
books Effie so this is my this is my new
deployment here some pods and we have an
error shucks
what is that let's take a look okay
deployment here we go
red text it says secret oops
secrets books Fe users not found okay so
why is this well turns out there's good
reason for this so here's a little bit
of a source code of looks like an
ornament to do this is a little bit of
the source code all that content
application and some of the stuff that
it does here is if it tries to access
some things in the environment and these
actually come from secrets and so the
secret doesn't exist
because we haven't created binding so
one thing that happens is when you
create a binding under the covers the
service controller because it's
kubernetes says well I'm going to
propagate these things in a secret and
then the application is configured to
expect that secret to exist and and
those those environment variables get
created from wrong values in the secret
and so kubernetes will just not launch
these pods if all the dependencies
haven't been satisfied so we will go
back and just create some bindings so
I'm going to go in here and for each one
of these for most of them when typing
here is this is a label so in kubernetes
everything is done you know specifying
what you want to address is all done
through labels so our label for our
application is books Fe I have to do
this three times so you copy that
the inventory oops that's one I did
alright we'd only do payments for the
purchases and then we will do the last
one which is users and what I didn't
show you if I did a cube control get
secrets you will see that it has a bunch
of them now that are it has a couple
that are a few seconds old books if the
inventory purchases and now there's
multiple users so that one just have got
traded so now those the secrets exist
and let's see what's going on with our
deployment so now when you go back
you'll see that the deployment is
actually now running so kubernetes just
figured that out
you know now those dependency is
satisfied so we have a front-end and for
now I am going to launch my app I'm
going to launch this the web browser for
for this app alright oh yes it works
okay here's my front end I have some
books it's getting from the inventory
and I am just going to buy one of these
it's a classic book and let's buy this
crock pot recipes and I can look at my
purchases and see that I have a couple
of things right there so let me show you
one thing I am going to show you the
secrets just as you can see how how how
those work secrets and then I'm going to
say keep control I'm going to I'm going
to describe that I'm going to look
inside of it and I'm going to pick one
of these look
oh just glad secret that was oh of
course I'm just going to do this I'm
going to cheat there we go
forgot that oh yeah mo okay so here's
here you can see from the data so this
is the hostname and port are being
passed in and then that came from the
binding so those originally came from
the service and the the controller
injected those into the application
through secrets and environment
variables all right so so now we're
going to make a modification so so say
that week selling books our publishers
are very interested in well let us know
when you when you sell phone books cloud
pub/sub might be a good way you know if
you publish events they can just
subscribe to those channels and then
look at them so in order to do that what
I want to do is I want to go back to the
Service Catalog and I don't have cloud
pub/sub so I'm going to add one and I'll
do it up here add catalog so I'm going
to create one called GCP okay bear with
me while I type it incorrectly and then
I miss something oh there look at that
thank you
all right double check the first time
I've screwed that up on all my dental
runs I've made other mistakes but not
that one
all right ah look at that a thing of
beauty so now we have four services that
our environment knows about that we
cannot create so let's just send though
for the time it's create an instance
create the pub/sub instance now the
interesting thing that I will show you
here is that when we create a binding to
it we're going to bind to it from our
application and we still want to use the
same application and I'm going to knock
hi some parameters remember earlier when
I said that we will have schematized
parameters in the future well that's the
future so right now I go to type in some
new JSON so it's a very small amount of
text and so this is just setting the
permissions on that does that look right
I think it does all right so we'll
create that binding so now I've said I
want to bind my application to that but
the application doesn't know how to talk
to the public object and so for a
purposes of making this a shorter demo
I'm not going to make changes the code
and we compile it we build my docker
image and everything like that what I've
done or actually what one of my
engineers did was basically make it
optional so that we actually can we have
the same code and it just knows it's
passed a parameter that says whether it
should use pub/sub or not so here's the
code for that
and so I just need to make a change to
the mo file that is one of our config
files save that and now if I update this
application
we should be able to see some action on
that deployment again all right Q
control get pods take a look at what's
in here yep you see one is terminating
another one is running so it looks like
we're up in business again will I leave
that window down oh oh oh
[Music]
that is surprising oh here we go all
right so let's let's buy a couple more
books in spy this one try this one and
now let's go back here and run a g-cloud
command so I'm going to call G cloud to
basically fetch from the subscription
channel it's called gtp next and ideally
everything works and we get something
back here we go okay so there's a
purchase that was made and see if we
have another one just a message ID not
very exciting let's see what else we got
that was it I made two purchases all
right so that's that's that piece and
I'm just gonna alright so now I'm going
to hand off no III need to go back to
slides please you show the slides on the
screen
perfect all right okay so what some of
this key takeaways this is the apps that
we modified and we showed how you can
easily connect to pre-existing services
from a new app and also how to provision
and connect to a cloud service in the
same way one of the existing services
the payment service here we didn't
actually deal with that but what's
interesting is that it's actually
exposed as a service as well and so
there's a way that you can wrap existing
legacy things as services and those of
you familiar with Cloud Foundry will
recognize that same capability and so a
lot of the benefits that you can see
especially in in Louise part of the talk
are then applicable to something like a
legacy Service like payments as well
because it now gets wrapped in this in
this abstraction we also showed how we
need no knowledge of where the service
came from or how to negotiate
credentials the necessary information
just showed up in secrets and then
environment variables now let me hand
off to Lois who will show you some even
cooler stuff all right Thank You Myrtle
okay so Martin talked to you a lot about
how people are going to acquire services
how we're going to make sure that the
services has well known relationships
with each other and now I'm going to
show you some of the things that you
know we'd like to do underneath all of
that to help make that work better and
help you get some insight into how those
services are talking to each other and
be able to start imposing policies on
the conversations of those services are
having with each other and there's a
term floating around nowadays that I
think is gaining momentum for all of us
and it's the service mesh you have lots
of these services of all talking to each
other it's not a network in the
traditional packet sense it's a network
of services and their relationships with
each other and all the things that they
want to do so I think it was a service
mess of a network for service so let's
talk about that a little bit so what
would you want to network of services to
do for you well when we don't service
this today we want reliability we want
them to perform well we want them to be
able to deal with transient failure
modes
maybe if I bring up a service and it's
talking to some other service and that
service has a failure mode maybe I can't
reach it maybe one of the jobs goes down
I'd like the network the service match
to take care of that for me we'd also
like the service match to help us with
performance when I bring up lots of jobs
and maybe I'm bringing up stateful jobs
and stateless jobs and doing all these
types of things in production and
routing traffic to a stateful job when
it hasn't had time to warm up its cache
it's probably a really bad thing to do
for latency and it might even be a
really bad thing to do for availability
if cache loading is a very expensive
operation you start with these cascading
failure modes we also want the network
the service mesh to help us with
visibility I'd like to know which
services are talking to each other I'd
like to know if their services in my
deployment that I don't expect to be
there so we'd like to have a lot more
visibility about what the behavior is in
this network and I'd like to have
control when a service is talking to
another service it would be very nice if
I could go and interpose in that flow
and say no you're not allowed to make
this communication your Europe you're
violating some sort of policy or you're
using too much for resource or doing
these types of things so how do we make
all of that happen we switch back to the
demo so meanwhile in offline
okay so while Martin was doing all these
wonderful things one of the things we
also spun up in the background is the
monitoring at all the services are
talking to each other at a generating
traffic wait a minute we switch to the
demo thank you um so here's the typical
graph on our dashboard it's showing you
the topic between the services no we're
showing you simple kind of requests for
second metrics and you can see that
we've annotated the graph with you know
the services right so you know that's
the books services books at the service
is talking to purchases is talking to
users and for some really strange reason
it's doing 60 TPS of traffic Martin I
see apps guys running low test in
production again okay all right let's go
stop that because that's just bad
practice and that looks like it was a
that was the books front end
let's see books friends and talking the
user service and Barton definitely did
not like fifty books a second so let's
go deal with that so we go back to our
instances and we can go look at the user
service and we see we have our binding
books from Darin talking to user service
okay so let's drag in there notice this
link adds Network function and see she's
very rough this is very mention and demo
alpha quality stuff at this point but I
go in here and say I have Network
function I can start to take some action
on the interaction between those two
services and in this case I'm going to
impose a quota
I don't think Martin really wants more
by more than five bucks a second by
books a second so I'm going to turn that
out now what happened under the hood
right the system is aware of this
binding it's going to take that notion
of relationship and it's going to push a
piece of configuration down into a
system and say hey I for this binding
this relationship between two services
we
Kota alright let's hop back on over to
Griffin a dashboard and see if anything
happens and look at that right between
the error rate start to spike out write
the books front-end services or just
load tests that Martin is running it's
still sending traffic but now we're
rejecting it
getting dropped and actually it's not
even going into the service itself it's
being dropped earlier in the network and
so we're seeing the requests will
actually start to cap out a slight GPS
the valid one and all the other traffic
is going to get rejected there are lots
of these types of things that we can do
in this network if we have this amount
of information if we're able to
interpose in the traffic in sensible way
so how do we do this type of thing and
can we switch back to the slides
well Griffin is very pretty we could
look at it for a few minutes if you like
we go back to the slide thank you
alright so how do we do this well the
first thing that we need to do is you
need to capture traffic we can't really
do anything if we don't know what's
moving around so here's you know a
little subset of the application with
the books app and we have users service
and the books app is pulling to use a
service fired API well in things that we
did before Martin started driving that
was going to fold a component into the
granted cluster might as part of the sto
projects which Martin does it to earlier
and it's called a taxi manager and what
the proxy manager does is it listens the
two bananas API and you spin a pod it
rewrites the pods on the fly and it
injects proxies into them then it also
rewrites the networking rules inside
kubernetes so instead of that traffic
going directly from the books front-end
user service it's actually going through
proxy and it's going through a proxy on
each side and we'll talk a little bit
about why we do those types of things
another we're capturing traffic we can
start to do interesting things with it
we could start to inject Network
function there's a different classes of
network functions but we'll talk a
little bit about some of them here maybe
you want to roll out a new version of
user service user service v2 you don't
want to send all of the production
traffic to it live right maybe you just
want to send one percent of the traffic
you want to qualify that service in
production and make sure it's stable
before you cut everything over the proxy
that was injected into the books at B
pod and now start to put the traffic on
your behalf and you can do this at the
operator level you don't have to go and
change the application code to do this a
very important thing
maybe user service is unreliable and so
instead of the books app having to deal
with the fact that it calls the book
user services are flaky the folks you
can actually do the retries on behalf of
the service itself and so as long as the
proxy has some awareness of what type of
operation is that ID imposing is it safe
to retry it can actually do these things
on your behalf and so if you have a
system where you have these kind of
intermittent flakiness but it's not due
to anything that you can direct the
control right now as an operator you
know it's very often you know the best
of bad choices to start turning on
retries of exponential back-off maybe
you want to move the service up into the
cloud maybe use the services as vast
enormous thing with hundreds of nodes in
seven different regions and now you want
the proxy to do smart intelligent things
on your behalf like load balancing right
maybe that those balancing is going to
be regionally aware maybe that little
bouncing you might want that load
balancing to do something like optimize
for latency right so you're going to
send all of your traffic to the most
local nodes possible until it starts to
fill up and then you'll start to short
it over to some other region maybe you
want to maximize for availability and
you just kind of keep an eye on the
backend help each service and the proxy
can be aware of now it's worth noting
but we didn't have to rewrite any
application code to do this as you
mentioned Martin mentioned earlier the
bucs front-end window jf I'm user
service may be certain and go and the
purchasing service is written in DES and
all these things it is a complex
polyglot environment implementing
sophisticated network functions like
these is expensive it actually takes a
lot of engineering effort to get it
right and to do it consistently and
consistency is what really matters here
right if one piece of this network
doesn't really play well you can start
to have a nasty things happen you can
have this gating failure mode and so
having the trucks you do this work in
your behalf is actually massively
beneficial right as long as it can
and that nodosum well you don't have to
worry about the application developers
consuming some fancy Network runtime
trying to write exponential back-off
code for the fifteenth time you just
don't want to be doing those things what
else can we do well we can inject
identity so another piece that is still
installed into the kubernetes cluster is
a certificate authority and when we
bring the proxies up they also inject
credentials into them those credentials
in the case of kubernetes are tied to an
any service account now the proxies can
use those controls with certificates to
enable crypto between the proxies right
so we can do mutual TLS action now both
applications both nodes of this graph
can strongly verify who's calling them
they know it precisely it's not just
some random piece of code running in my
cluster and always something running
with that authority even if the users
application isn't written using some
standard protocol maybe it's not using
HTTP right maybe a database of the zone
propriety binary protocol so leave you
task tunnel the identity all the way
down interest as a protocol doesn't
matter or doesn't would let you do that
but at least you know the traffic
between those two nodes is secure and is
types that identity if it's type of that
identity we can start to do something to
this we can start injecting policy
associated with it right
maybe the books application is owned by
Martin's development group and maybe the
per user service is owned by my group
and you know I think he his development
team is a bunch of cowboys and I'm just
going to shut them all right I can do
those types of it lots of interesting
things we can do with policy for another
component that gets injections the tuber
Nettie's environment is a thing we call
the mixer and it can do a wide range of
things so I showed you earlier we showed
you monitoring right we inject this
component and the proxy sending all this
information to it about the behavior of
the network and we simply flow that into
Griffin
flouted super weakened super fine and we
had some life - for something like that
I can visualize my network and the
debate of the services between them I
knew we could have done that with slack
driver or a scimitar almost I'm 12
we also decode it right and in the
example that I showed you we have a
quota component running inside this and
it on the user side it said hey you know
I'm supposed to enforce five DPS of
quota and they just prevent the calls on
that server-side proxy you prevented
them from actually getting into user
service and if it was mutual trust and
we could have actually done that check
all the way back up at the book side and
the project will never again hit the
physical network um but you know in
worlds where you have you span multiple
Foss boundaries you really do need to
make sure that you enforce acolyte
checks you know in the same class domain
as the server but also the develop
implication and aqua so maybe you know
that you have multiple authentication
schemes in your network maybe even a
wall for sewing jobs or who knows what
and those credentials are flowing
through say HTTP calls you can delegate
them out to this service and it can make
sure that they're consistently enforced
across the network and also you can
report actual policies right if I have
that notion of identity whether it's you
know a mutual TLS identity maybe it's
the tool and a service again maybe it's
something else
doesn't really matter or you can use
that for Macklin checks and you you know
a lot of companies out there have
standard a quality system and you can
use this to integrate that and this is
probably the most important point is
that this system is easy to customize
right so what we've really done is set
up a framework where we provide a whole
bunch of standard signals about the
traffic flowing between services and
then we provide this convenient runtime
integration points you can go and put
control over that traffic actually will
know which service it came from which
service is going to what the operation
is what region it came from what
credential or identity does it have how
big is the thing you can enforce
whatever policy one
right so this makes for saying the
current implementation is written in go
we think goes a good language for people
to write extensions in and to plug them
into this framework and then just deploy
it enjoy cluster okay
so conclusion you know we have our
principles and Martin talks a lot about
these in the beginning and you know the
big one being service is not
infrastructure right what we're trying
to focus on is services as units that
you can find acquire consume and then
utter a right not the lower level
building blocks necessary to do all
those types of things right bringing the
level of obstruction up we talked about
interoperability and in particular that
the open service broker API right the
community effort and you know you showed
you a way to bring services from other
environments into your workplace right I
could I had my own catalogue I could
take Google's catalogue it could take
some other vendors catalogs bring the
mam and start to work with those things
or maybe as an internal thing right I
just I create my own catalog and I
curated and that's all that my internal
developers are allowed to use and
there's this qualification process to
get things into the catalog and then we
talked about automation we want to make
sure that everything is automatable
alright so we walk you through where you
I and we showed you a bunch of command
line stuff and I did some things and you
know in the enforce policy and then I
showed you some of how that works but
everything here is driven by an API
alright so if you want to change the
policies around how services talk to
each other you make API calls to do that
right you probably need to have a lot of
privilege to do it but that's what you
should be doing and so you can start to
automate the role level services
automate the acquisition of services
from third parties and do all the
offensive this is internally open this
is a collaborative effort and Google is
not doing this on its own or anything
like it and so Martin talked about the
open service broker
he also talks about the true brand
service catalog and I talked a little
bit about the service mention is key oh
and use the companies that we're working
with on a daily basis to make that stuff
happen so here some useful links and you
can go in all of these links read about
this stuff as Martin warned you at the
beginning things are alpha sharp Twinkie
dangerous borderline unreadable maybe
you have to read the code to figure out
how it works it could be quite painful
so hopefully the next time we give this
talk that the nice shiny dots when you
go follow these links and everything
will be entirely understandable and you
know you'll be using it and you wouldn't
need to ask me any question
[Music]
you
[Music]